welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and we're back with
a whole host of new information on the
upcoming Matt Reeves Batman movie every
week same bat-time same bat-channel
we do a big breakdown on all of the
updates on the film and this week
there's a lot to unpack throughout the
video we'll be discussing the new
Batsuit information the hidden easter
eggs in the film's logo the potential
catsuit release date and a lot more
there may be some spoilers here so if
you don't want to know anything about
the film then I highly suggest that you
turn off now make sure you subscribe to
the channel to never miss an update on
the movie and without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking the video now let's get into
our breakdown of the Batman okay so we
still haven't had a look at the bat suit
just yet but there's actually been a
couple of big social media posts this
week that tease what it could look like
and confirm a couple of things
earlier in the week skull 101 if I
mocked up some fan art using the Batman
a well suit from the game Arkham Knight
and Robert Pattinson's chin now there's
thousands of these kind of images across
the internet now even we even tried to
sneak in some of myself to try and go
viral but no one picks them up however
not only was this image posted by heroic
Hollywood it also got shared by Lieber
Meho who said oh the irony here now why
this is important is because bemay ho is
actually the artist who created the
quote-unquote Norwell suit and after
designing it all the way back in Batman
/ deathblow after the fire it's made
appearances in all of the books from the
artist initially there were reports that
Batman's costume for the film would draw
heavily from the Bermejo design and the
artist did also reshare some fan art
late last year which seemingly confirmed
this could Bermejo posting oh the irony
here signify that this is actually very
close to the bat suit that fans have
been eagerly awaiting well personally
that's how I take it what if this image
is so close to it that it's ironic we
are waiting for it when we pretty much
already see what it looks like we don't
know and the post Suns so enigmatic that
the Riddler himself could have written
it but I definitely think it wants more
cooperates that we will be seeing
something similar to it in the finished
product some diehard Dark Knight fans
have been calling out for the white
glass eyes for a while to be brought
across the final design but it looks
like we're going to be getting the
mascara Laden cowl that we've seen in
every live-action version of the Batman
so far this is because Robert Pattinson
was seen out and about earlier in the
week and a fan got a photo of him that
clearly showed the actor wearing
guyliner
maybe he's born with it maybe it's magic
marker but it did send the internet into
a flurry over what was going on a lot of
people said he looked tired some said
he'd taken Kristen Stewart's mascara in
the divorce and others said grow up and
stop watching comic book movies while
sin Ischl e people did think that we
were making a mountain out of a molehill
the actor did appear later with the cast
of birds of prey and he seemingly was
wearing the eyeliner once more we even
got to see Harley Quinn having a bowling
match with Batman and yeah the group do
seem to be having a great night but
where was my invite and what does this
signify well as the Batman is shooting
right now it does seem to confirm that
we will be getting the eyes in the cowl
films tend to always want to show eyes
as they massively help to a moat and I
did suspect that this would be the case
with the Batman the MCU thought their
way through this with Ironman after
placing in a helmet cam and spider-man's
eyes of course reacted things as they go
on Batman has always been a bit more
difficult but it looks like they're
keeping in line with the Bermejo cowl
and bringing the eyes and guyliner once
more as for the logo you may have seen
that we discussed recently that Matt
Reeves posted the clapperboard for the
film and its first day of shooting fans
actually blew up the text that was on
the item and placed it on a white
background and is actually a lot of cool
little Easter eggs and hints for fans
firstly I just want to give a huge shout
out to Chris at 3 C films for spotting
these and definitely go check out his
channel for some awesome movie updates
anyway it was revealed that the letters
themselves all have hidden little
tidbits in them that add a lot more
weight to the theory that this will be
used as the final logo for the film if
we zoom in on the a we can see why is a
silhouette of the penguin Colin Farrell
is of course playing the villainous
crime boss of Gotham so this is a nice
little nod to him there are also aspects
of
the logo that look like Gotham's skyline
we do know that the movie is shooting in
Glasgow and now the city doesn't really
have a collection of skyscrapers that
could be incorporated into its
architecture it is possible through CGI
that this is suggesting they are going
to be adding things digitally Gotham is
of course a huge metropolis and with
Glasgow being a typical city in the UK I
do think that this highlights that the
structures may be added in post there's
also a crevasse that looks like it could
have a question mark symbol there for
the Riddler or even a backwards R Chris
did say that it thinks this will be a
hint towards Robin and after we know
that the film will be based on the long
Halloween it could indeed be the case
now Welsh Robin doesn't feature in that
book the graphic novels direct sequel
dark victory actually centers around the
origin story of the character so it is
possible that they could be setting it
up throughout this movie I'm not 100% on
that but yeah it does definitely provide
some food for thought before we get into
the rest of the video I just want to let
you know we're giving away a free copy
of dr. sleep to one random subscriber
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the updates in the comment
section below the winners gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of February
in the settle be shipped out from the
until they get surprised it's the best
of luck to everyone who takes part okay
so according to the Daily Record a
message was posted on the american
muscle's scotland facebook group that
said that the batman was requesting fans
bring in american cause from the 80s all
the way up to present day to feature in
the background of scenes we did
originally speculate that the Batman
will be set in the late 90s early 2000s
but this post has made something that it
will be set in one day personally I
still think it may be a period piece and
these cars will have been put in place
to give the movie a more timeless feel a
lot of properties such as Batman 1989
and the animated series have pulled from
a lot of different time periods in order
to create the overall feel of Gotham and
it would make sense to mimic this here
with audiences being unable to get a
proper feeling of exactly when the film
is supposed to be set we also learn a
lot about the feel of the movie this
week with a brand new interview YouTube
channel hey you guys come up with the
composer
Batman and this is what he had to say
about the movie and working with Matt
Reeves in general you know I love those
big sort of event film Star Trek Star
Wars whatever all the Marvel stuff I
love all of those it's really fun to be
a part of those because that's what I
loved as a kid you know and and now it's
like you know just to look back and see
all those things every one of those
movies is something that I either had a
comic book of or or watch the movies as
a kid and I just it's so weird to be a
part of it right now I'm in the middle
of beginning some stuff for Batman and
that is a really fun thing to be a part
of because again I love the Batman you
know as we all do growing up so it's
just fun to be a part of taking it and
doing your own version of it so it's
nice I was gonna ask you about Batman
actually I'm such a huge fan and it
seems like this is a very different take
to what we've seen before has hazmat
giving you any kind of guidance in terms
of the comic books he's he's obviously
you can't tell us but I can imagine he's
picked a few stories that he maybe wants
to try and capture the tone off Matt and
I have talked about this for well over a
year now and you know I mean we're like
best friends so we talk all the time
anyway so it's it's this is just normal
part of our conversations wouldn't it be
cool if we did this it wouldn't be fun
if we did this and you know let's take
it in this direction do something
different and you know that's what we're
just trying to do is to take it and do
our version of it the thing that we
would want to do and hopefully that is
different from everyone else's and and
tells ever it gives them you know I used
to love going in and see everyone's
different take on you know you'd get a
comic book series and it would be a
whole new take on the character and that
was always fun to do and that's what I
feel like we're being we're a part of
that that whole tapestry at this point
it's just a fun equation I mean the cost
is is pretty extraordinary anyway but
obviously your friends room I mean what
has he given you any indication or did
as he told you why specifically he
wanted Robert Pattinson or was that kind
of a process or you probably can't tell
me too much but here's Robert Pattinson
and it's very distinct again very
distinctive and a very different choice
what we've seen before I think it's
always a process you know you're always
kind of going through whittling down and
figuring things out but I knew I think
from day one he knew that you know he
was into me he's an amazing actor he's
an incredible actor and in this business
you get pigeonholed for certain things
if you do one thing you know and it goes
off well then that's the only thing
you're gonna be known for
so it's for someone like him it's really
that's not a fair assessment he is an
amazing actor who can do pretty much
anything you know and that's what I'm
excited about to see him in this role
doing something different have you seen
the suit yet or are you waiting like the
rest of us I've seen it so it sounds
like they're doing a new sort of take on
the character that we haven't seen on
the big screen before and I'm really
excited to see how this comes across in
the movie and finally there's actually a
lot of buzz online that we may get
either our first look at the cat suit
bat suit or both on Valentine's Day
according to insiders Warner Bros could
be releasing an image of comic books
biggest Caped Crusader couple to
celebrate the special occasion but we
are yet to verify this it does seem to
be flowing about and there were actually
a couple of tweets flying around that
have since been deleted let's say we may
see something similar to the image on
screen right now this would not show the
Batman but it would tease the costume
slightly and give us our first look at
Catwoman who as of now hasn't had much
hype surrounding her I think this would
be an awesome thing for fans and though
I'm not sure whether we will see the bat
suit just yet
it is good to hear that the release may
be right around the corner would be
amazing to get this and then another
image of the bat suit and Batmobile
together later down the line putting a
tease of Batman in is definitely one way
to get people to share the image of
Catwoman and Valentine's Day is a day
that has been dropped a couple of times
online and in terms of the release day
that we could be getting but I guess
we're just gonna have to see now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the updates and what you want to see
in the film comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
please give it a thumbs up make sure you
subscribe to the channel but updates
like this every week same bat-time same
bat-channel
you want to watch more DC stuff then we
just dropped a video on the birds of
prey which is gonna be linked at the end
you break down everything you need to
know about the group before the movie
comes out so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know who's
who in the comics you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below you get access to content early
you can also suggest video topics and
breakdowns we massively appreciate it it
goes a long way to helping videos like
this get made if you want to come chat
to us after the show
either follow us a definition YT or
click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time
take care peace